wer einen blick in die zukunft werfen
will der bekommt bei der consumer
electronics show in las vegas einen ganz
guten eindruck hier entwerfen die
hersteller die vision einer welt in der
es mit selbstfahrenden autos keine staus
und keine lästige parkplatzsuche mehr
gibt maschinen sollen krankheiten
deshalb diagnostizieren als der mensch
und kleine helfer sollen den alltag
erleichtern
zum beispiel dieser hunde sitter roboter
dir vor du bist im büro und dein hund
allein zu haus und du kannst den roboter
mit dem smartphone steuern oder ihn
kannst du mit deinem hund in kontakt
bleiben
roboter werden zu partnern und freunden
alles scheint möglich im bereich des
sogenannten maschinellen lernens welchem
zeitpunkt wird die konversation mit
digitalen assistenten zur beziehung über
kurz oder lang werden sie in
konversation mit uns treten statt wir
mit ihnen die botschaft der hersteller
ist klar
der technische fortschritt soll das
leben unkomplizierter länger und
produktiver machen dass er auch seine
schattenseiten hat haben die
sicherheitslücken bei
computerprozessoren jüngst deutlich
gemacht der optimismus der branche könne
sich als naiv erweisen warnen kritiker